you notice this was difficult this was
tricky right what scan is it keeps on
turning and twisting and orientation and
it gets you ahead a bit confused right
now
masks notice this as well he's like this
way it fills the curb sure but it's
armed it's hard to wrap your head around
okay so so therefore he thought I want
to do a way that retains its orientation
okay
the better leb ESG beauty okay now in
order to do that in order to have
something that doesn't keep twisting and
turning he had to kind of inverted
commas break one of the rules okay
so here's his curve he went in this one
I'm gonna put the numbers in for you
okay he went like this 1 2 3 3 D and
then 4
okay see see it's very very similar to
this order 1 2 3 4
he's just flip this upside down so do
this work to start here and end here and
visit all the points he has to do a
diagonal here we go it is kinda cheating
isn't but what he's trying to do he's
trying to solve this problem like this
is confusing it gets very very complex
right so you can see watch this watch
what happens when we do it this way okay
if you can go with this if you're
content to break the rules in this way
right when I do my best curve of the
best curves right I'm gonna start down
in here this is the first one I'm going
to do right and then I want to end here
1 into 2 you see that one into two I'm
gonna go one into two so he's where you
guys
makes his n okay and then he's like boom
I need to get up into here right so what
he does is he's just like well I've
already broken the rules that you can't
do diagonals but as well just break it
again and he goes like so okay
now having started here he can just copy
this shape watch this okay no confusing
twists and turns but again you see you
have this you're trying to fix a problem
you create a new problem
if I go one two three four where must I
go next I've got to go all the way down
here
right now I'm trying are the whole point
is to keep the orientation so that means
I should really be and you sign there
right so that means he's going to just
like you did here Traverse all the way
through here right in order to get his
copy of the original curve right and
then the same thing key word so what's
he done
okay he has still visited everything
hasn't he
right he's gone let's see one two three
four five six seven eight
so he's doing it block by block is a
simpler kind of way he doesn't have to
twist and turn right so let's see if we
could do if you can have a go at giving
these to a shot and doing its third
iteration for the best curve okay I
actually because one the easiest ones
because you just okay